hello YouTube chest lowers in offense
this is one Jean here and today I like
to share one of my big success with you
what I've done over here is I have
opened the Google and I'm going to type
chess results so that will come up with
few links and I'm going to open the
first link so that will be redirected to
this one of the biggest online chess
server now chess result has listing of
current recent international and
national level tournaments and not only
that they have the big database of the
results so if you haven't check out this
website I certainly recommend that have
a look to this website now if you can
look at over here they have
distinguished by the countries and I'm
going to click India that will open up
the listing of the current two domains
running in India so this are some of the
listing and from this list what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open this
link which is tilt chess club and above
and the buzz is the city where I'm
living right now and this tournament was
held on 28th for 2013 and the time
control was five minutes with the three
second increment so this was the blitz
to lament and if I can scroll down and
see the starting ranking list so you can
see this one I am was also playing this
tournament which was very high rated -
four to one and there are around eight
people who are 2000 plus and around ten
people of 1900 plus and if I still go
below
that is my name so I was listed on 28
and my rating is 1771 which is of course
a feely rating so that is the starting
scenario where I was listed on 28th
position and now if I'm going to click
the final ranking that will give me the
list of after completing the ninth round
what will be the final result so if I
can show you the result you can see I
was secured 8th position and this is one
of my biggest achievement in any
tournament if you can see the points
over here I have secured 7 points out of
9 and including two drawers and only one
loss and if I click on my name that will
show you detailed analysis of my
performance my reading performance is
1753 and these are all my opponents you
can see a third table I draw with 2200
plus and also drawn with 1907 and I beat
1988 and also beated 1725 the only loss
I got is from this guy hatin shop which
was ranking around 1979 it will shine as
a big name because there are a few
videos on YouTube specially Kings
crusher has made it the name is
something like this a nine year old kid
beat the GM so he was talking about this
guy when he Cuccia was nine year old he
beat the GM
my position was very good in the game
but somehow I didn't manage on time and
I lost it nevertheless from this listing
what I have did is I have picked the
most exciting game in this tournament
which was I have played with this guy
and this round was very very crucial
because if I managed to win this game
then and then I can survive in the top
10 and which I did now before we see the
game
this guy has recently played the under
2000 Indian open and he beated two to
three nineteen hundred plus players and
drew against a couple of eighteen
hundred class players so he is right now
in a big form and to beat him is like a
big achievement for me especially in the
last round so let's see this game now
the last round was very very crucial for
both of us because we both have to win
the game to survive in top 10 and in the
game he was white so he started with the
movie four and here comes the move which
I have specially prepared for the
tournament which is nc6 and nimzowitsch
defense the good news to all my
subscribers are that I'm going to launch
my first ever chess recruiter against
efore which is nc6 system very very soon
so please watch out for that
me and we shall have played few times
before and he is a very good scotch
gambit player but my track record
against him is very very good and he
knew that I'm a very good player against
the scotch campaign so in this game he
decided to surprise me with this move
which is f4 which is a kind of a Kings
gambit structure then here I responded
with the Bou ePHI and after the main
line nf3 here comes the big surprise to
him because I shocked him with this move
which is fi this is known as a delayed
counter gambit and those of you who
haven't watched my previous video I
certainly recommend them that please
watch out my video of a delayed counter
gambit which teach you how to play and
neutralise the Kings gambit I have also
highlighted here in annotations so you
can also click this link here we shall
probably thought about 20 to 30 seconds
and then he goes for this line which is
e cross F I and in the video I recommend
that you should play E for which I did
and here he played ng for system now the
good thing is in my previous video of a
delayed counter gambit I haven't
included this variation so it's good for
you to
learn what you should do when your
opponent plays ng4 here the bird obvious
response is nf6 because Queen to h5 is
in air so I played n f6 and now here we
shall plays v4 which is okay mu which
free of the two bishop but the downside
is I can play now D Phi so I have a very
good Center and my last move create the
threat of capturing the pond so he goes
for this a grassy line which is g4 so
protecting that pond and here I renew
the threat once again with this move
which is catch file now please note h3
is not possible because SG and white
cannot recapture so Michelle goes for G
cross H file now before we look at G
cross h5 there is a one nasty trap over
here that if white foolishly play Bishop
to e2 then black is going to capture
that pawn and after white recapture that
will again capture the bishop and after
Queen captures here comes the whole idea
which is n cross default and now you can
see that two threats looming first is n
cross F 5 second but the most critical
one is n cross c2 so white cannot defend
both the pole and the resulting position
is very much favorable to the black so
that's why probably he knew this threat
and that's why he played at this
position G cross edge file here I
captured F born with the bishop which is
bishop cross f5 now it's time to have a
look into the position for a moment why
it has an extra pawn but that is a
double pole
that can be a soon target where black
has a tremendous development just for
the one my sleep on and you will see how
dynamic black position is as the game
progress the only good side for the
white is white has a wonderfully posted
night on G Phi which cannot shift it
immediately now please note right now
the black two pieces are attacking the
edge file and if black does not defend
it then black will regain the pawn and
then black position will be very very
superior so in the game we shall played
Bishop to e2 so defending that pawn and
I decided to play Queen to d7 so my idea
is very very simple
I want to castle on the Queen side and
then just go for the King side so here
he played the first inaccurate move of
the game which is Bishop to b3 and I
exploit it immediately so I played n g4
so attacking the bishop
please note Queen d2 can be successfully
made with the NV 4 so for example a
simple line after Queen d2 can run like
this so Queen d2 and b4 now the threat
is very very simple black wants to
capture this Bishop and then capture
this c2 Pole so most likely reply will
be n a3 afterwards black can castle on
the Queen side and please note white
even cannot castle on the Queen side
because the a to pawn will drop if white
play aggressive moves such as c3 then
black and simply give this check and
after very force reply Bishop cross d3
black and we capture this pawn and you
can see there are so many threats are
looming so first is black can capture
this Knight and give another double pawn
set to the white and not only that this
rook can also come to the e-file where
can pressurize more to the special so
all in all this is wonderful position
for black and Frick showing it's around
five point plus to the plan which is
very obvious so in the game instead of
Queen to d2 my opponent decided to play
Bishop to f2 and idea is very simple
he wants to reroute that Bishop to
either g3 or h4 but I know if I all this
possibility by capturing that Bishop and
after white recapture I played Bishop to
d6 so attacking the lose f4 pawn and why
defended with King to e3 so it's very
funny that within thirteen moves white
king is strangling in the center but
white position is fine there is no
immediate threat right now to the wine
so that's why he can play King to e3 and
now I Castle on the Queen side so now
I'm all set to go for the White King
side and here why it has to play very
very energetically otherwise he will
lose very very quickly and which he did
so special plays nc3 so attacking my d5
pawn now here probably I thought around
one minute because I can see I cannot
play Bishop to e7 or Knight to e7
because that will lead this white knight
to jump into the juicy c7 square so
after a long thinking I decided to play
Bishop to b4 keeping in mind that a 3
and B 4 can be occurred and here I think
we both were in the time trouble that's
why probably he didn't see what disaster
is coming it's very attractive for y to
attack this Bishop and once I drop back
he once again attack this Bishop so in a
way white is gaining time on the bishop
and also attacking black on the Queen
side but after
Bishop to b6 now you can see the dark
side of this pawn would so now there is
no way white can defend this pawn except
Knight to b5 which he did but after very
simple a6 that Knight has to move and
then once the knight has been moved then
the critical protection of the D file
will be gone so in the game my opponent
decided to play c3 and give up the piece
so I capture the piece and then he
recaptured that phone with the bishop so
which has a merit of pinning my knight
but afterwards my moves are very
illogical so I played Bishop to g4 not
only attacking the Queen but now I'm all
set to capture that pawn and open the
Kings side of the white so my opponent
decided to go for the desperate counter
play and he plays Queen to e4 so now the
threat is very simple he wants to give
me the check from the 8th here I was
under 10 seconds and I have to admit
that I didn't see King to be it although
I think of it for a glance but I thought
that after the bishop and the Queen
captures white pawns on the Queen side
will be very very strong so I decided to
give up the exchange by playing Queen to
d6 and hear my opponent plays Knight to
c7 and after Queen to f6
he grabbed my rook on the default and
here I recapture with the King so my
idea is very simple now if the Queen
check occurs then my bishop can always
come back
and that means I cannot lose rook so in
the game my opponent decided to give me
the double pawn so he captured my knight
and after I recaptured he plays this
group Ashe to effing so which has an
idea of protecting that pawn but the
move which I was waiting for so long
which is Luke cross h4 so now with this
move I can threaten root 2 H 3 as well
as Luke Ross H 2 and white cannot stop
both the threat in the game
my opponent decided first to give me
this check which is again a one kind of
mistake because after King to d7 his
queen has been misplaced it's completely
out of the game now in the view of
capturing this pawn my opponent decided
to play rook to f2 but now because the
White Queen side has been open up the
game didn't last long
first of all give this Shack and after
the only move King to d2 now I played
Queen to h4 so my opponent defended with
other rook support and here again I was
under the five second and I have to
admit that I haven't seen the move III
but nevertheless the move I played is
not that bad as well so I capture that
pawn and again the threat is very simple
I want to catch that rook and my
opponent definite with King to even but
after very simple rook takes and rook
takes I give him this check and probably
I think he was in the time trouble as
well and he played this disaster move
which is king to d2
and here I was shouting like yes yes yes
because I knew it is checkmate in two
and it's a very simple one so first of
all the squint check and after the only
reply came to e3 this is a checkmate so
that is a critical game which I have
managed to win and the good thing is is
also show you how to handle the position
after white place ng for system I hope
you enjoy my first ever success in the
tournament as well as this game please
feel free to comment on my video and I
will meet you soon bye